if you were on the run from demon
hunters what would you do the only home
you ever knew is gone and now you're in
a demon world where everyone will hunt
you down for food i'm going to break
down the mistakes made what you should
do and how to beat the demon world in
the promised neverland season 2. these
kids have no idea but they're all about
to die if they can't face the horrors in
this demon world because their freedom
has never looked so horrifying all of
these kids are orphans survivors from
the human cattle farm known as grace
field and they try to survive everything
that this deadly forest offers them just
as they stop to catch their breath just
then one of them fiddles with a pen the
very same pen that fellow orphan norman
who's dead left behind for them with it
they activate a holographic image
deciphering the morse code the gang
breaks it and finds a message offering
to help the kids if they need it from
the same mysterious man from season 1
william minerva the gang further breaks
down the codex and figures out the
coordinates of a mysterious place in the
distance that they should head to and
with the gang having nothing else to
rely on they trust this eerie message
and start making their way there but
suddenly they see a giant monster coming
for them the children run for their
lives and try to outwit this terrifying
beast by splitting up but all of a
sudden the monster gets killed by none
other than these demon hunters who can
now sense that rays nearby and demands
that he come out or else okay now listen
good these demons standing on two legs
are similar to humans in terms of being
similar size and build but that's where
the similarities end what they do have
that we don't is superhuman speed and
reflexes now that's all we know for now
but let's be honest there's no way that
we could take this demon out not yet and
knowing that there are variations of
demons out there means that it's a safe
bet that some at the very least can
catch our scent if we let them in this
instance it's fight or flight and i
would definitely choose flight but our
odds of running away are pretty slim
since mr demon has his pack of wild dogs
with him so our best bet in this
instance would be to use the varying
flora around us to better mask our scent
by quickly rubbing dirt leaves pine
needles and anything else that we can
find to mask our scent this way we'll be
better able to stay hidden at least
temporarily while these demons are
within our vicinity i mean come on we're
only kids and at this very moment you
know there's no way in hell that we can
take them on trapped and with nowhere to
go rey comes out and claims that
everyone else is already dead but these
demons don't believe a word that this
brat is spouting and chase him down the
rest of the gang in the distance wonders
where rey just went and they suddenly
hear the distinct noise of a whistle
right as they begin to figure out that
what they're hoping for isn't true that
the demon hunters are near and are going
to get their flesh but fortunately for
them their bad luck is cut short just as
emma passes out someone suddenly calls
out from behind them and offers to lead
them to safety this strange girl
elsewhere rey continues to run
frantically as he is hunted down by
these demon dogs eventually cornering an
exhausted ray and they prepare to drag
him back to hell itself where it all
started the human cattle farm where he
came from but all of a sudden his limp
body is snatched by a mysterious figure
on horseback and he throws some scent
blocker grenades losing the demons for
good but this isn't over and the demons
won't stop until they find them later
rey wakes up to find himself in a
strange bunker and finds emma resting
there too none of them know what the
hell is going on looks like they were
helped by someone and that certain
someone was strange girl who pops up
from behind them and calms them down by
telling them that they're safe but this
strange girl keeps the two kids on edge
just as another strange man appears from
behind them rey knows what emma begins
to fear that their helpers are in fact
demons themselves emma and rey demand to
know where the other kids are and the
demons tell them which way to go they
rush off only to find the kids
comfortably gathered around a camp fire
the demons then introduce themselves as
mujica and sanju and that they're
heretic demons that don't eat humans all
the while as they feed the entire gang
food but something is up and rey and
emma later go confront sandra about what
the hell is really going on and he tells
them that because of their faith as
social heretics they don't eat humans he
then tells them the world they live in
is not really how it appears and tells
them of a war a thousand years ago that
happened between demons and humans and
that a truce was formed with both sides
agreeing that neither side would hurt
the other if they stayed within their
half of the world segregated and
separated from one another and that some
of humanity that was left behind on the
demon side would be used to create human
farms meant to feed the population of
demons okay emma needs to seriously
reconsider her way of thinking and
potential rescue operation of the
children within gracefield house because
initially we didn't have any idea as to
the realities of our situation but we
now know for a fact that gracefield
house isn't the only human farm out
there and that the rest of the world or
at least half of it is run by demons
this makes the chances of us managing to
help our brothers and sisters escape
from their almost zero and it's unlikely
that we ourselves will be able to change
the status quo since literally half of
the entire world operates this way if
i'm a little girl called emma then i
would screw saving anyone else and i
would live out the rest of my days
hiding out within a safe bunker or
hidden location with whatever orphan
buddies i got left because realistically
there would be too much that we could do
and just like any old border i doubt the
human world would be easy to cross into
if this has been the way of the world
for the past 1 000 years the one thing
that emma lacks is the ability to
disregard the feelings of others for the
greater good and this is one such trait
that'll cost her dearly soon emma and
norman then jump up and down after
hearing what they think is good news but
the demon says that they'll never be
able to cross into the human territories
and mentions that in the thousand years
since the truce was made no one has
crossed between the two worlds but emma
and rey are too naive to realize that
they'll likely never get there and have
no idea of what hell awaits them on
their journey the next day sanju and
mujica lead the kids through the
maze-like tunnels as they guide them
towards the way out emma and ray then
update the kids on what sanju said and
of their mission to meet this mysterious
william minerva first before figuring
out how to cross into the human
territories only then will they be able
to save the rest of their orphan buddies
from the gracefield house sanju and
mujica over the coming days leading out
of the maze teach the kids how to
survive on their own in the wilderness
and even teach emma how to hunt the day
then finally arrives as the kids venture
out of the forest and into this desert
canyon hemojika and sanju bid the kids
farewell right before mujica gives emma
a charm for good luck but this group of
orphans don't realize that sanju has
other reasons for letting them escape
and it's way more sinister than anyone
could ever imagine later on the orphans
reach the coordinates and find out that
the secret location is not what they
think it's an underground bunker and
they discover the eerie entrance into
its lair and they begin to search the
empty halls and corridors of this
strange cold place but they're in luck
because they discovered this place has
everything they could ever need food
security soil for farming water and they
even discover a letter which welcomes
them on getting to this bunker by none
other than william minerva this is
insane these kids have literally hit the
jackpot and have found the ultimate
bunker but it can't be trusted just yet
and they should take the proper
precautionary measures to make sure that
this bunker truly has all the basics
they need to make sure that this place
is truly self-sustainable and they
should also make a note to dispose of
their scents from the ground trail
leading up to the bunker entrance as any
scent has the potential to last for
about two to three days on the ground
and could get picked up by demon hunters
if we fail to cover our [ __ ] up and this
problem can be taken care of with a home
brew mixture containing some 3 peroxide
distilled water baking soda and some
unscented soap if the last one is
available now when it comes to the
actual bunker these kids will need to
check if there's proper air ventilation
installed that will be able to last for
weeks if not months they need to check a
steady supply of water or water
filtration they should also check for
perishable goods for starters first aid
warm clothes on the likely chance that
their bunker does not contain some kind
of crazy insulation between the walls
and did i mention they'll also need
tools for general maintenance and base
repairs and batteries because even if we
do have it i wouldn't count on us having
a steady supply of electricity and all
of these kids need to start thinking
about this before they let their guard
down and relax ray then discovers a
radio which they use to listen in on the
status of gracefield house knowing the
exact time that their mom used to radio
in but they hear nothing of note and
they decide to check the radio daily for
any updates on what is going on at their
old orphanage later emma and the gang
find a locked door with a keyhole and
manage to open it with their pen and
they find a scary dark crimson red door
before they get to a room with a phone
booth and even a horrifying dead-end
room with scribbles of the word help
etched into the wall along with a list
of names carved right by it just then
the phone lets out a bellowing roar and
the gang holds their breath someone is
calling them emma then musters up some
courage and answers it hearing the voice
of none other than william minerva he
lets the gang in on his real name being
james rattray and informs the gang that
he used to be a part of the farm
management team that ran the human
cattle farms but after seeing so many
kids die he betrayed the demons and
began leaving clues throughout the farms
leading anybody who could decipher his
clues to this underground bunker minerva
also tells the kids that they can choose
to spend the rest of their lives in that
bunker or they could try and get to the
human world and he gives emma
coordinates on how to get there should
they decide to leave this comfy place
and face the horrors of the unknown that
await them and the demons outside these
little orphans then decide that they
will make a life within this bunker
first before going to rescue the rest of
their brothers and sisters from
gracefield house and then they will all
venture to the human world together as
one big happy family or so they think
months pass as the orphans make this
bunker their home but nothing is built
to last forever and that's when their
happiness finally runs out suddenly a
massive explosion erupts at the front
entrance of the bunker alerting everyone
that shit's about to go down and in
comes in swinging special kid abducting
forces who descend down into the bunker
and search every nook and cranny that
this bunker has looking for the fleeing
orphans but these little kids are crafty
son of a guns and manage to hide in a
secret room while they await this hell
to blow over but they're missing two
people just then don and this kid here
get found by the soldiers forcing him to
outwit them and retreat to the hidden
room where the gang is before they flee
through a secret second exit located
right below the bunker forcing all of
these tiny little children to run for
their lives okay this group should have
been prepared for this at least a little
this is an apocalyptic world and our
only home is one bunker left behind by a
man who we have no idea if he's even
alive or not they should not have
expected this bunker to last forever and
they should have prepared emergency
drills practicing to all meet at a
certain spot within the bunker in the
event of an emergency this way don and
that kid with the white hair could have
known and reacted faster right as the
explosion went off they also should have
made it mandatory to carry weaponry on
them at all times such as forks and
utensils of which don here could have
used to better handle that soldier this
is a case example of failing to prepare
and preparing to fail because as the
oldest kids emma rey and don should have
known better and prepared for the worst
in advance just then a soldier spots one
of the kids aiming his gun right at them
but these two kids are too fast for this
guy causing him to fall off the cliff
but the fleeing orphan's troubles aren't
over because these soldiers end up
capturing a bunch of them causing rey
and emma to give up but suddenly out of
nowhere this horrifying demon monster
bust through the trees ripping up every
single living thing still standing
allowing the kids to flee and run like
hell as this monster then starts to
chase them down and elsewhere their luck
continues to get a whole lot worse
because back at some unknown prison sits
the woman who raised all of these
orphans to die mother herself and the
demons make a deal she'll get her
freedom and the kill switch removed from
inside her chest if she manages to catch
every single orphan who once called her
mother and she accepts vowing to hunt
all of them down no matter the cost the
next day the kids make their way to a
demon town and put on some disguises and
sneak into the marketplace the kids
glare and peek around at all the various
flesh-eating monsters who crave human
flesh but the kids notice something
these demons are in fact not that
different from humans as they go about
their regular day and even see some
demon kids run past them showing these
orphans that the world is a little more
complicated than they realize the gang
eventually makes it back to their
hideout a demon heretic church where the
rest of the fleeing orphans are hiding
out and they hand out what little food
that they found emma is dying inside of
the situation wanting to give her family
a better life but the kids laugh off
their sad situation and emma and rey
discuss their uncertain future with
little food and no hope they can't go
back to save the rest of the orphans
from gracefield house not without a
proper shelter the next day the group
heads back to the demon marketplace to
pick up some spices for their captured
fish but due to the wind currents their
scent gets discovered by these demons
who then begin to suspect that there are
humans nearby until suddenly a final
gust of wind gives off their human scent
for good the kids then run like mad as
these two demons chase them down to
enjoy a special meal okay while these
adorable little snots are adorable
they're even dumber than they look the
wind dictates greatly the amount that
ascent is dispersed into the air and
just like hunters this group of kids
should have accounted for wind factor at
least slightly as their disguises only
fell apart when the demons caught the
kid's scent they already caught fish the
fact that they felt the need to go to
the nearby market for spice while they
are wanted fugitives is beyond me when
you're a wanted fugitive you do not make
unnecessary trips yet in the instance of
the gang getting discovered the group
messed up on the one advantage that they
ended up gaining as a result of their
running and that was the fact that they
led the demons down that deserted alley
no one's around they had the weaponry
and the skills necessary to kill them if
they had just pulled themselves together
and not to mention they've lived on the
demon side of the world for some time
now so it's not like they've never seen
a demon before the fleeing orphans run
terrified flying past all the street
walks stalls and cellars and they split
up but rey and emma get cornered they
are trapped suddenly a demon jumps down
from the rooftop and even more demons
corner them but the two initial demons
still try to fight for their delicious
food but then all of a sudden this demon
lets out his sweet ezio-style assassin
blade and cuts them down for good
revealing to be none other than the very
same orphan they thought to be dead
norman he's alive so cue the waterworks
and a good old buddy slap to the face
because the gang rejoices once more but
they have no idea the consequences of
reuniting with norman later on emma and
rey fill norman in on how they escaped
and norman reveals where he's been all
this time and the truth couldn't be more
horrifying back in season one he wasn't
sent to die but to be used as a lab rat
for intelligence experiments at a
research facility called lambda where
they used norman and other intelligent
humans to figure out how to raise human
livestock more effectively the horrors
of what lambda has planned will make
those human farms seem like nothing
norman also reveals the most horrifying
insane thing ever and the reason as to
why demons need to feed on humans
because if they don't their bodies and
minds will regress turning them back
into terrifying creatures without any
self-control this is why they can't stop
feeding on humans the gang is then
shocked to the core but norman says that
using data that he stole from lambda's
lab he has weaponized a drug that can be
used to regress demons intentionally and
that he has enough of the stuff to
destroy the whole nearby town but emma
has a huge problem with this and she
thinks that all demons are just like
humans with their own lives and families
and she can't help but think that this
is a terrible plan the next morning emma
and rey are introduced to a few of
norman's escapee friends that he also
helped escape from lambda's facility and
they come to realize that everyone here
hates the demons and can't wait to kill
every last one of them but emma finally
gathers up the courage and tells norman
how she really feels telling him that
the demons are forced to eat brains to
live and that means that they're not
that different from humans who simply
want to survive and that the humans have
to be better than the demons if they are
to co-exist in this world okay while i
do appreciate emma's ability to have
empathy she's not thinking with her head
but with her heart but in reality the
way the status quo has been for a long
time over a thousand years will likely
remain unchanged due to the demon
society's reliance on human farming from
the non-egalitarian ways to the poor
people's dependence on meat to survive
and not to mention the whole noble
classes who will surely put up a fight
when [ __ ] hits the fan there's just no
way that emma would be able to stop the
production of meat or the public's
reliance on meat consumption without
absolutely massive effort and resources
that she doesn't have not to mention
that no one has crossed through to the
human portal in a thousand years and we
don't even know if the human world would
let us enter their side they very well
could turn us away and send us right
back to where we came from this means
that there are way too many variables to
plan for and it makes her plan in
wanting to save everyone so unrealistic
it's nauseating norman at the very least
wants to incite chaos by putting up a
fight to rid this world of the demons
and if we compare his insane plan based
on brute force to emma's heartfelt
non-violent one well i believe it's safe
to say who's plan would really be a more
efficient solution norman pays little
attention to naive emma's ways as he
reveals the regression drug right then
and there in all of its glory but the
party is cut short as emma then tells
norman something seemingly insane that
there are demons out there who don't eat
humans and that she's seen two of them
herself sanju and mujica and that's when
norman freezes up thinking that there's
no way that the heretic girl could be
still alive norman freaks out hearing
only the rumors that began over 700
years ago about a demon that could
survive without eating humans and could
turn other demons into being just like
her through drinking only a drop of her
blood but norman's so intent on making
sure that this plan succeeds he thinks
that sanju and mujica pose a serious
threat to his weaponized drug plan which
means he has to kill them now this
freaks out goody two-shoes emma but
norman lays it down logically for the
girl saying that they likely won't just
sit by and idly watch as their own kind
is destroyed which means sanju and
mujica need to die emma then reveals her
reverse uno card and shows that she has
the coordinates to the human shelter
meaning that they can just run away to
the human world rather than kill all the
demons but norman shuts her down again
and says that her map has been
compromised and that the man himself
william minerva and all of his
supporters have been killed emma's pure
spirited heart drops for a sec as she
tries to find her words but norman then
reveals that there is in fact one more
portal that will take them to the human
world located deep below grace field
house itself the very same orphanage
that they all grew up in but norman says
that there's no hope of them reaching
the portal alive and that killing all of
the demons is the only shot at surviving
within this world however thanks to
emma's drama queen nature and bdis
norman agrees to try emma's plan first
by finding and utilizing mujika's
abilities to help the not rely on human
meat anymore and that emma has five days
to find sanju and mujica before he'll
begin his plan to test his weaponized
drug on the nearby village little does
emma know that norman is full of [ __ ]
okay emma is the most kindhearted person
that i know but i think she might be a
little loco and a bit of a deadweight
because her plan is full of holes and
with no guarantees whatsoever we can't
know for sure that mujica will let us
use her to help mankind as we never
discussed this before and there's little
to no certainty that if we can't
convince her that she'll just sit back
and let us resort to plan b which is to
literally kill all of her own kind so
really norman's plan is the only plan
that sounds like it will actually work
and it is the same plan that has the
least amount of variables to account for
and so with this being said we need to
be the most cruel and most savage
bastard that we can be and like norman
take matters into our own hands if i was
norman i'd resort to going to extreme
lengths to make sure that emma doesn't
mess up our plan since she's really the
only one who has any contention with it
norma should have known that emma would
not go along with this and that she will
get in the middle of his plan one way or
another which means we need to shut her
up permanently or tie her up if we don't
want to kill her and prevent her from
meddling with our [ __ ] until the first
phase of our plan is over which involves
the decimation of the village because we
can't take any chances with her or rey
for that matter the next day norman
waves rey and emma goodbye as the two
set out to find the two heretic demons
but norman has other plans and talks
with his teammates who reveals that
thanks to lambda's experiments they
don't have much time left on this earth
and will soon die which means that they
don't have time to wait for emma back at
the children's hideout at the heretic
church emma fills in the rest of the
kids with the situation that she'll set
out to try and find sanju and muchika
and over the coming days the gang
searches high and low in this mysterious
forest looking desperately for sanju and
mujica using what sanju taught them to
find clues left by them within this
forest but the wild is a terrifying
place because all of a sudden this
monster busts through looking for flesh
causing the gang to split up and fire
arrows right at this beast nearby
elsewhere sanju and mujiga hear the
nearby roars just as moojika notices the
amulet that she gave emma hanging on a
bush which means emma must be nearby
this beast is literally 100 times the
size of us and all we have are these
arrows and our brains now this monster
has the advantage but what i'm certain
about is its weakness by the dozens of
eyes it's sporting i'm pretty sure if we
hit one of those it would hurt a lot but
trying to get a clean shot from far away
will likely be hard as hell so we need
to close the gap between this demon and
our arrows and this is where the varying
trees around us could prove to be
advantageous if i was emma and rey i'd
work together to make this demon chase
after us and hide within some of the
exposed tree roots that some of these
ginormous trees are likely to have now
unlike us increasing weakness with age
is not a universal law of nature and
this can apply with certain trees
because as they increase with age they
can get stronger and judging by the size
of these trees in the background i'm
pretty certain they can take a pretty
good punch so what emma and rey could do
is make a run for it identify certain
exposed tree roots and hide within them
then once this beast gets close enough
trying to eat us we could use our bows
and arrows to puncture its eyes this
step could be repeated dozens of times
until the creature becomes completely
blind or runs away from being unable to
reach us being too difficult of a prey
to eat this is the best way that these
kids could bridge the gap between their
arrows and this monster's weak point its
eyes just then as emma runs for her
sweet life and about to get devoured
whole rey comes in sliding like hawkeye
and shoots an arrow right into this
beast's eye hole just as sanjo appears
and slices its head clean off saving the
day mujica then comes to emma's aid as
she tells them that she needs their help
but the sweet moment is cut short by a
large eruption in the distance right
where the demon village is and it's at
that moment that emma and rabe realized
that norman lied to them and the chaos
ensues as demons left and right
throughout the village are plagued by
the effects of the drug losing their
sanity composure and mind and they can
do nothing but watch as their bodies
regress into horrifying monsters men
women and children demons all mindlessly
turn on each other feeding on everyone
it is at this moment that norman and his
comrades descend from the hills just as
norman prepares to kill this little girl
right before he stopped by this old
demon the same old demon who was at the
heretic church where the orphans took
refuge in earlier norman then readies
his blade but chokes at the last moment
hearing the old demon call out to his
granddaughter calling her the same name
as that of his best friend emma causing
norman to freeze in fear and regret he
can't kill the innocent norman's free
spell is then broken for a quick second
right as he tries but fails to kill the
old demon forcing the old demon to make
the little girl drink his blood causing
all of her regression to stop meaning
that this old demon is just like mujica
just then emma shows up to the village
and convinces norman making him realize
the despicable acts that he's caused
forcing him to come to his senses
showing up late to the party is sanju
and mujica who begin donating their
blood to help cure the regression turned
to demons trying to end the horrors that
norman and his team started and with no
time to waste sanju tells emma and the
gang to quickly retreat before people
find out who did this and everybody
heads back to their demon heretic
hideout but as they return they find out
from the radio the worst news of all
that their orphan buddies back at
gracefield house are about to get
shipped out meaning they're about to get
chopped up for meat little do they
realize that this is all a part of their
old nemesis mothers plans to lure the
kids back to gracefield house the orphan
gang then sits back and plans their
attack just as the old man demon appears
and says that he too is a heretic demon
with special blood and that he found a
device on the body of a facility worker
who collapsed just outside of the
facility that norman escaped from and
gives it to emma he then rants about how
he could have given his blood to the
demons and saved them all these years
but was afraid of being exposed
basically siding with emma and her team
and making everything hunky-dory again
what's up anime weebs dom and albert
here we gotta chime in you know we can't
let griff have all the fun so albert
tell me what do you think about season
two what are your thoughts i understand
the criticism of season 2 because season
1 has so much great horror moments in it
but season 2 feels more like an action
movie well this at this point the kids
know what they're doing you know the jig
is up we know about the demons and all
that so it's about them fighting back so
like the mystery was kind of taken away
you know what i mean and also we don't
know their overarching story because
their goals keep shifting every episode
at first
and then they wanted to go to the human
side and then they wanted to free the
demons i think they should have had a
better overarching goal that we could
follow that's true that's true but yeah
you know it was a good watch overall
though but oh god albert the demons have
found my hideout but real quick 80 of
you guys watching and not subscribe so
be my best friend and subscribe but now
back to the video emma then turns on the
device that the old demon gave her and
finds out that these are the blueprints
to gracefield house and its underground
base and everything that they need to
get to the human world turning the tide
on their war with the evil demons as the
gang including norman prepared to save
their orphan classmates and escape to
the human world however the night before
their big rescue plan this glasses guy
picks up the radio and begins conspiring
with lambda head peter ratry and he
makes a sinister deal all the orphan
kids in exchange for his freedom the
next day the gang sets the plan in
motion readying hot air balloons filled
with regression drugs to take the demon
security out as the others plan to
infiltrate the plants from the hot air
balloons and get the kids out before
guiding everybody to the human portal
just as these adorable little snots are
led blissfully unaware to the human
slaughterhouse the hot air balloons
finally reach the perimeter as demons
begin to take them out one by one but to
their surprise the balloons are empty
because it turns out glasses guys set
them up suddenly a huge explosion erupts
from the hot air balloons as dozens of
demons die and sanju drops in like a
stud and kills the remaining demons
elsewhere emma and the kids reach the
tunnel location and head underground
slipping in through the back of the
plant and taking out this demon as
glasses guy hacks the security cameras
blinding peter rattree and his demon
army the smallest of the kids dress up
in the same uniform as the orphan kids
getting shipped out and slip in while
the mothers leave the room helping all
the little orphans escape before locking
the mothers inside the entrance walls
everybody finally reaches the majestic
portal hall entrance way right as they
get surrounded by an army of mothers
looks like peter rattree and mother were
onto them from the start but nothing is
as it seems and the mother pulls a
double whammy backstabbing peter
ratchery revealing to him that all the
mother's kill switches inside their
bodies were neutralized when glasses guy
hacked the entire system earlier if
peter ratry went through the trouble of
implanting all the mothers to ensure
they don't double-cross him then maybe
he should have thought about
implementing a second failsafe switch on
the off chance the main one didn't work
because relying on one method alone and
hold all of these mothers hostage is the
dumbest thing that he could have done
and it's not very super villainy of him
in fact this was about as evil as those
bad guys in films who always spend about
10 minutes telling the good guy their
entire evil plan only to have him escape
eventually if peter rattray wanted to
ensure that no one would ever betray him
then he should have been diabolical with
his insurance strategy hear me out now
if i was an evil supervillain running
from a human meat farming business i
would have had the mothers impregnated
from the start of their career through
ivf fertility treatments and then after
i would have taken their newborn babies
from them to be raised in a separate
non-meat farm facility for life this way
on the off chance that one or all of the
mothers managed to escape or disarm
their implanted kill switches then we
simply could have used their very own
children as hostages i know i know 2020
hindsight's so sad but this would have
been a cool alternative and also sounds
super diabolical i like it peter
ratchery laced cornered with his back
against the wall but has one last trick
up his sleeve because he reveals that a
backup demon army is coming to kill
everyone in this room but in an
absolutely insane twist of events it
turns out that these demons are not here
to kill the kids but peter ratry and the
demons running the meat farm and we find
out that sanju and the old demon used
their blood to cure all the demons from
the nearby town freeing them from their
dependence on human meat meaning they
don't have to feed on humans anymore to
survive but peter ratry doesn't give two
shits about any of this sweet news and
condemns emma and rey claiming that
humans will simply destroy and mess
everything up that they've worked so
hard for right as he exits stage left by
slitting his own throat emma then
forgives mother for everything that she
did and invites them and all the mothers
to join them in the human world an offer
of which she gracefully accepts but
right before they enter the portal emma
ray norman and his teammates and some of
the demons tell the little kids and
mother that they'll stay behind to
rescue all the kids within the demon
world and that eventually they'll meet
again as the grand entrance portal door
closes behind on emma as her and her
crew set out to save the rest of the
kids within the demon world and go to
change the course of history for the
first time in 1 000 years and if you
don't want to get cancelled after season
2 don't forget to like subscribe comment
and check out the how to be playlist
down below